aj thank you very much indeed for
talking to us
this afternoon and now i want to come on
to talk about boxing in just a moment
but
firstly i want to ask you about the
breaking news from last night about
tiger woods you cited him as
your inspiration what was your reaction
when you heard the news of his
car crash i actually watched his
documentary like two weeks ago
and what a phenomenal talent and
it just shows the importance and like
how much importance he has in his
industry and how much people care so i
hope he's well i'm praying for his well
wishes
and then anyone that's around him as
well i hope they can send that message
to him and just say he's got so much
love and support
you are finally expected to fight tyson
fury
later on this year what's the latest
you've been teasing us
on social media yeah i try not to do too
much teasing
it's coming close to the point where
things are getting back to normal
so we're working towards a date around
june and uh if tyson
is serious which i think see which i
think he is they'll know where to come
and fight the boss
and uh i'm ready i'm really looking
forward to competition all i want to do
is fight fight fight i can't wait to get
back in the ring
so june potential date boris johnson
announced this week restrictions
in england going to be lifted later on
in june is a fight on home turf
completely off the table are we looking
at the middle east
any option home turf middle east my back
garden your back garden i don't mind
where it is
i'm just ready to fight fight but i want
that bell
i want to compete with tyson fury so
honestly all options are open to me
and what about in in front of fans how
important is it to you
to have a big crowd there it was a
blessing to have a thousand people in
attendance i fought last year december
12th
and even though it's like a thousand
fans it makes a big difference
so to hopefully get to ten thousand
twenty thousand and then
the whole world being back to normal
having like ninety thousand to a hundred
thousand people in the stadium
i can't wait i can't wait to rock the
show and bring some entertainment back
into people's lives
how has lockedown been for you you're
living with your mum
are you homeschooling as well what's it
been like
you go through different transitions one
minute like it's super dad's schedules
and then there's a bit more freedom
then there's that point of you know do i
actually like my life
you know when you're sitting there after
like three months of doing the same
thing
to actually like my dog you start
questioning everything around you
but um then you come to realization that
it's a time that we're all in together
and there is an outcome
to this to this situation the pandemics
obviously had a huge impact on
professional sports but i wanted to ask
you about
sports and the impact that it's had
amateur clubs playing a huge role in
communities and shaping young lives
needed more than ever at the moment now
it's time for like
people who these kids look up to to kind
of take lead and try and do
certain incentives to keep them
motivated so like we've done a project
where we went to my local school we've
done like a
training program for kids we've done
some stuff for boxing
we helped with doing zoom calls for some
certain kids are having problems in
school
because obviously the whole transition
from being at school to now
zoom calling like my little niece i live
with her and she's gotta be on a zoom
call at seven
she sleeps at six and wakes up at 6 59
to get on a
class you know and it's like keeping her
motivated to keep a good discipline
when i first got into sports it wasn't
about the competitive edge
i have that anyway like most people but
it was more about the mental health
aspect where i wanted to
cleanse my body cleanse my mind put my
mind
positive so even like with the sun
coming out now
going on a run going on bike rides it
will make
such a big difference and also seeing
the light at the end of the tunnel
leading towards summer there's real
concern about
vaccine hesitancy in black asian
minority ethnic
communities is that something you're
seeing
and what do you think we can do about it
just have these conversations bring the
light to people
i think it's good if people who have had
the vaccine discuss their experience
with it and then it will encourage
people who haven't
had the vaccine to understand what it
takes and
what the importance is of taking the
vaccine as well so i think what the main
goal is
all getting out of this together and
moving towards
normal times one conversation that you
have taken part in black lives matter
you took part in the march
in watford last year i wonder what you
think about wilfrid zaha saying
he's no longer going to take the knee
because he
considers it to be degrading do you see
where he's coming from
i feel like everyone's entitled to their
view so i have to understand where he's
coming from
because that's his own specific view and
i understand the people that do take
their knee as well because it's bringing
awareness to a situation that
people have been trying to fight for
many many years
it's just about unity not about because
this person chose one route and this
person chose another i don't appreciate
or respect them
it's just about respecting people for
their individual views and coming
together
and just understanding one another
person who wants to take a vaccine
respect you and person who doesn't
respect you come together and have a
conversation and we respect each other
for
our independent views yeah now the ioc
have said
no political protest and they consider
taking the need to be
a political gesture at the upcoming
olympics it's a global stage it's a
really powerful place
uh to make a statement what would you do
if if you were there this time around
it was something that my teammates and
all of us have made a conscious decision
to do
i'll be in support of something positive
like that if i'm honest with you
if it's all for positive change i'll
definitely take the knee
at this stage the plan is they are going
ahead
in tokyo can you see it happening i can
see the olympics happening
i'm close to the boxing industry and i
speak to my coach who's head of the
boxing olympic committee
and he says it's going to go ahead and
the kids just need to kind of stay
motivated
i feel like it's tough for them because
they've spent a year
and a little bit more not knowing what
they're going to do with their careers
do i turn professional do i stay amateur
the thing with boxing is that if you can
stay amateur and you can conquer the
amateur game you can become
one of the leading figures as an amateur
olympic gold medal
world champion european champion it's
like you're penciled on to go into the
professional game
and conquer but they want to go there
and prove how good they are but with
everything going on they feel like time
isn't on their side
you said last month you might only have
uh five
years left in boxing
does it feel like a long time ahead and
what would you like your legacy to be
and what what else will you do what next
my legacy
would be for people not to understand
what i mean today
but to grow to acknowledge some of the
positive things i try to make a change
i don't really ask for much i don't
think i can do much for everyone but if
i could spread positive messages
and bring a smile to people's faces
like yourself there i've done a good job